[Music]
one year on from seizing control of
Afghanistan the Taliban rule with a rod
of iron
Afghanistan now suffers under one of the
most repressive regimes in the world
oops we
mediums
this is an islamist police state which
has stripped women of their most basic
human rights
that is the image of what they want the
women of Afghanistan to be wearing every
day it is a country where schools for
girls are forbidden and those who defy
the ban live in fear of beatings and
imprisonment how scared are you I'm
terrified
that they'll come and find us
now I've come back to Kabul to meet the
women who refuse to be silenced as they
fight for their right to exist
for us is the question between life and
death
either we are going to die or we are
going to live
[Music]
I love my love
[Music]
I've never
been to this country when there hasn't
been
guys with guns everywhere they're just
different guys with guns now
every time I come to Afghanistan I'm
excited coming
but there's also a really heavy feeling
of dread
[Music]
leban sees power
the West had abandoned its 20-year
commitment to rebuild Afghanistan
and left Millions to their fate
thousands of people descended on the
airport desperate to flee the Taliban
sorry
and it was in the midst of this chaos
and the countdown leading up to it that
I was approached by dozens of Afghan
women pleading for help
one of those was brishna who I found
hiding in the outskirts of Carvel
rushner was one of the foremost
advocates for women's rights in
Afghanistan and for that she was being
hunted by the Taliban
her position was so serious we reached
out to the authorities on her behalf
who recognized that her life was under
threat
you have been
up for evacuation to the United Kingdom
by the British military
[Music]
escaping the Taliban wasn't easy and for
weeks she was forced to hide in a series
of safe houses operated by a network of
extremely courageous women
eventually brushner made it out today
she lives safely with her family in
Nottingham
[Music]
safe is mixed with the guilt so common
with survivors
the guilt at leaving so many behind
I'm always worried about them I can't
even sleep
is there any message you want me to give
when I go back to Afghanistan
if you could just go and meet them see
them and hear them and be the voice for
them
I'll try wow
Krishna
brushner's greatest fear and mine is
that the women of Afghanistan are in
danger of being forgotten
and that's why I've come back
to find out what's happening to those
who've been left behind
[Music]
my arrival coincides with the first
anniversary celebrations of the
taliban's victory over the world's
greatest superpower
God calm down calm down
calm down I'm trying to get your opinion
[Applause]
all around me the streets are packed
with revelers and there's not a woman in
sight
[Music]
it's only men and
yeah you should not join a woman with a
man
because Islam don't allow the uh the
mixing of men and women
it's obvious that there are men In This
Crowd who hate me and everything I stand
for and working here is going to be
tricky
the thing that you notice particularly
in Kabul is that the Taliban are
everywhere they're a very pervasive
presence a very intimidating presence
and they're keeping a close eye on a
strict control over what's allowed and
what's not allowed
slipping away from the celebrations I'm
off to visit somewhere that once
embodied the hopes and aspirations of a
whole generation of women
only a year ago this building had been
at the center of Afghanistan's powerful
new feminist movement
not anymore
I'm told this writing says Afghan women
won't be silenced anymore and the whole
of this building with its murals used to
be the department for women's Affairs
which was shut down as soon as the
Taliban came to power this big image of
this woman demanding her Freedom with
the words saying Brave just above above
her has now been obscured by this big
black smudge over her mouth signifying
that they've now been utterly silenced
foreign
irony upon irony I'm now being silenced
this this is my search why
so so now we're being I think we're
being summoned to see this guy's boss
because we're not allowed to um to film
and we're being told that we need to see
the person who's in who presumably is in
charge of silencing women
I'm going to be treated differently
because I'm a foreigner but this is what
it's like for a woman in Afghanistan now
you can't even complain about not having
a voice
and for those who do fight back the
punishment is severe
[Music]
this footage of a peaceful protest by
women demanding the most basic human
rights was filmed a few days before we
arrived
the Taliban response is Swift and brutal
so you're saying go now
being hauled into a police station in
repressive regimes like the talibans is
never going to be anything but
nerve-wracking but this time it seems
we're lucky I think I think I think
they're a bit embarrassed about being
followed in by a load of men and cameras
so we're just being told to leave now
rather than the whole embarrassment of
having to deal with a foreign woman
that though is the image of what they
want the women of Afghanistan to be
wearing every day this this is all this
is all they want to to see and they
don't even want that
[Music]
treatment to protesters here is the
starkest form of the Taliban clampdown
on women
but the impact of their strict
interpretation of sharia law is evident
in everyday life
from the compulsory headscarves and all
covering clothes to the insistence that
wives walk behind their husbands
talking to women in the street is nigh
on impossible so my next visit is to one
of the few people brave enough to speak
out we're on our way to the safe house
where I first saw brishna the mother
that I met up with again in Nottingham
and this is the place where she hid out
before the fall of Kabul to the Taliban
and I'm going to be meeting one of the
most remarkable women I have ever met
she's the woman who runs a safe house
and who gave her sanctuary in the hour
of need
[Music]
yeah
here on the outskirts of the city is the
house run by mabuba siraj
[Music]
it's a rare place of Refuge from an
increasingly brutal regime
these women and children have been here
some of them for quite a moment and
they're all Abused Women and young girls
of Afghanistan from different parts
My booba's Sanctuary is long established
and predates the Takeover of the Taliban
by many years
[Music]
past 12 months the numbers seeking her
help has reached an all-time high
when the evening meal's over I sit with
mobuba for the first proper catch-up
we've had in months
what do you think about things here now
or year on has anything changed has it
got worse well
um
one thing that I am I know that is
happening
we are becoming extinct
in Afghanistan
women Taliban don't want the woman to
exist
I've really noticed that they can't deal
with us for some reason that's why
there's no schools that's why there is
no work that's why the women are not
supposed to be walking on the street but
just saying that my booba is it's a
staggeringly depressing statement right
I mean very it is so depressing
I cannot really tell you
I cannot count on anything you know one
day everything is fine and then the next
day somebody can come and as I said it
shouldn't second I said something and
they didn't like it and they're going to
kill me
does that make you feel scared no
why not how does that not make you feel
scared I don't know I swear I don't know
I find it so ridiculous I think I find
it so so annoyingly childish this whole
thing I find it so insulting
everything else happens to me but scared
no
that night I leave the house with mixed
feelings
a very real sense of anger at what's
unfolding
but I'm also inspired by mabuba
and it's her example that I cling onto
as my journey back takes me deeper and
darker into what's happening to the
women of Afghanistan
[Music]
it's been a year since the West pulled
out of Afghanistan
[Music]
and the Taliban is celebrating the
anniversary of their victory
but while the men here are euphoric
millions of Afghan women have been left
feeling abandoned and betrayed
[Music]
hello hi it's Alex
hi everyone how are you I'm good how are
you
I'm not okay
I've managed to make contact with more
of the women I'd met in the weeks
leading up to the fall of Kabul
sabir and her sister had been terrified
when they first approached me
they explained that they were on the run
from the Taliban because they'd worked
for both the British and Americans in
promoting women's rights
who's that guy do you know his name but
in the end all their efforts counted for
nothing they're pleased to flee the
country went unanswered
they were left to fend for themselves
now a year later I need to find out how
they're coping under Taliban rule
[Music]
we were just sitting here and without
any hope
how do they make you feel as a woman as
an Afghan woman
I'm feeling like I I have done something
really wrong because I'm a
I'm out of my house it's been months
that I just once get out of Hope
it takes days of planning but eventually
we finalize arrangements to meet up
sabir the woman on the phone arrives
with her sister farida and cousin Amina
at a secure location
none of these are the women's real names
for them the journey across Kabul is a
dangerous one and they're clearly shaken
by the risks
we were scared about that and we are
still scared that if they find us or if
they follow us with our documents so
maybe it will be our last day
you think that they'd actually kill you
yes from David class they have no other
way they don't have any rules they just
killed people
so there's no doubt that they will kill
us
a year ago the sisters were a
high-flying lawyer and a human rights
activist helping women in their struggle
for equality
but the arrival of the Taliban changed
everything
how would you describe just how much
you've lost and how much it's changed uh
actually for me it's
a load of
stress a lot of pressure a lot of
sadness everything a mixture of feelings
that I can't even describe what's
happening with me
her sister has also been silenced in the
cruelest way imaginable farida was once
one of Afghanistan's most celebrated
painters
but no more
I gone to my small gallery and the
talbon took all of that and broke that
and they banned my gallery and told us
that you can't work on faces of women
how did you feel when they told you that
it was like
killing me
now we don't we are nothing
we are empty
we don't have hopes we don't have dreams
it's heartbreaking to sit and listen to
women who only a year ago had so much to
offer
now their sole desire is to escape from
the country whose future they once hope
to transform
[Applause]
[Music]
Afghanistan has always been a male
dominated Society but the taliban's
extreme version of sharia law
means it's now even harder for women to
be heard at every level
in this sprawling Market a woman is
brave enough to protest about life under
the Taliban
[Music]
Academy
[Music]
she tells me she's lost her job and her
children are starving but a crowd of men
quickly forms around her
and she's been told to go away
[Music]
the man who tried to stop his filming
has called the authorities even though
the threat of arrest is now very real
I'm more determined than ever to hear
what these women have to say
assalamualaikum
um tell me how much do you make per day
two dollars a day are you just selling
this
what is it
a herb a kind of herb what can you do
with it make soup but the Taliban have
caught up with us
foreign
[Music]
ever since I arrived back in Kabul I've
been trying to make contact with the
group of women who organized the
demonstrations against the oppression
they suffer under the Taliban
foreign
now after days of careful negotiation
they've agreed to meet me
Hi how are you very good thank you
only a year ago these Highly Educated
women held positions of power and
influence
they were lecturers lawyers lawmakers
part of a new generation of feminists
forging a new future for Afghanistan now
they're reduced to hiding in safe houses
taking huge risks to highlight their
plight to the world
we organized our last big demonstration
a few days ago
why did you join the mall we were
calling for freedom and food and work
and also for the education of all women
[Music]
to become violent
after 30 minutes
[Music]
the Taliban came towards us and started
firing in the air in the ground
and we started running away
we ran anywhere we thought we could be
safe
he shoot on us they shoot on us
they came looking for me and tried to
take my mobile but I wouldn't give it up
one of them hit me two three times on my
arm with their rifle and all of me to
delete all the picture of demonstration
otherwise he would shoot me in reality
you could be raped you could be tortured
beaten we know what we are getting into
we talked about every possible outcome
in order for us to gain something
sometimes we have to lose something
that's why we are the sacrifice and we
will remain the sacrifice
if I'm being completely honest sometimes
I find it quite difficult to maintain my
composure
when I'm listening to women who
I look at them and I see
myself their fellow females their fellow
women I see my daughter or my mother in
them
I know they're being extraordinarily
Brave I know that some of those women
have stood in front of guns men with
guns who are itching to kill them
[Music]
and I look at their little kids they're
little girls
and think I wonder what kind of
future they've got
well at the moment that future is really
really Grim really bleak
no education no job no rights
I think I think if I was a man I'd feel
really ashamed
they should feel ashamed
so
singing
it's been a year now since the West
abandoned Afghanistan
I've come back to find out how women
cope under the brutal repression of the
Taliban
so far it's been unrelentingly bleak
but now I've come to a place that may
offer at least a glimmer of hope for the
future
your sister's also training to be a
doctor so there's two going to be two
doctors and do you feel safer in an
all-woman environment yeah actually I
feel safe
the students here are in the final
stages of their studies at one of
kabul's leading women's universities
a Caesar of face to me there are
currently no restrictions on women
attending higher education in
Afghanistan
and these students are the country's
next generation of gynecologists and
pediatricians
are you going to actually show us how to
do it
we uh
yeah
for me it's a pretty special moment
theories everyone wants to be adopted
here and he is passionate about being a
doctor
it's the first time since I've arrived
back in Afghanistan that I've been able
to spend time with women who aren't
being terrorized traumatized or silenced
Valerie just even being in this room
with all this talent and all these women
who want to change the world want to
change Afghanistan
doctors are usually really vocational
but because of the circumstances they've
been brought up in because of the the
challenges that they've had to get to
this point it's pretty awe-inspiring
actually
foreign
but there is a problem
universities may be open to women but 80
percent of girls in Afghanistan are
denied access to secondary education
and the students here are deeply
concerned about what that means for the
future of their country
about the girls coming after you obvious
might happen to them obviously a lot do
not study well they have been there
crying that why we didn't have this
permission to study you can study it but
we cannot if I was your younger sister
and I saw my older sister going on and
training to be a doctor and I wasn't
allowed to I'd feel a bit oh yeah upset
and Lord I saw my cousin and I saw her
because she's in cholesterol she said
I'm near to you because I want to study
in higher education but now I cannot I
have the situation a lot so how can I do
it I said I can't do something because
it's nothing we can't do and if the ban
continues I'm worried I could be talking
to some of the last women doctors to be
fully educated in Afghanistan
and in a country where traditionally
patients are treated by Medics of the
same sex the implications are horrendous
what happens if we don't have female
doctors if you don't have female doctors
all women of Afghanistan will need to go
to male doctors which many people do not
want including me I don't want my wife
to go to male doctor my wife doesn't
want it my mother didn't want it and
that's why she died
so we are playing with life
[Music]
Beggar's belief that the Taliban had
chosen to deny so many women a role in
the country's future but that's
precisely What's Happening Here
none of those girls want to do anything
with their education
apart from helping others apart from
helping fellow Afghans it's like who
wouldn't want that who wouldn't want to
encourage that who wouldn't want to tap
into that that that incredible energy
and determination
growing network of courageous women who
are refusing to be dictated to any
longer
we're going to see a secret underground
school because the girls are so
determined they're not going to give up
studying
[Music]
this school is one of dozens that have
sprung up in Kabul since the Taliban
banned girls from secondary education
your dream
my dream is now children doctor
Allah I want to be a teacher as you know
Afghanistan has not a good economy
because of that I want to be an
economist
do you want young volunteers teach core
subjects like maths and English as they
look to lay the foundations for a better
tomorrow
[Music]
it's really enlightening to see all of
these young people who are determined
they're going to learn whatever it is
staggering that they stand up knowing
that they're doing something that the
the people in Authority don't want them
to do and say I still want to be a
doctor I still want to be an engineer I
still want to be a teacher
I find the courage shown in this
classroom by teachers and pupils alike
is truly inspiring but I know everyone
here is taking an enormous risk in
simply going to school and I see how the
Relentless oppression these girls face
every day is beginning to take its toll
how scared you are coming to school
I'm very scared of coming and studying
at school
because being a girl has really been
outlawed here
how do you feel about that tell me how
you feel about that
it's the worst feeling to see that girls
in the rest of the world are free to
study sometimes we just think of
ourselves as criminals because that's
how they treat us being a woman is very
hard in Afghanistan
this is the reality for millions of
women under the Taliban
a daily struggle against a regime that
despises their freedom
but the refusal to be silenced extends
Beyond just the secret classrooms
later on we're shown a group of women
determined to defy the taliban's
insistence that they serve men merely as
wives and mothers
this Workshop is run by one of
Afghanistan's most formidable human
rights activists and what I witness here
is a magical process of transformation
okay
you turn all these
weapons of killing into something that's
beautiful
men kill each other with these bullets
but the women here turned them into
jewelry and sell it so they can buy food
for their family
these are works of art with a message
and that message is
that we women want a world without
fighting taking us to a different
location Layla shows us her team of
dressmakers and seamstresses
like the jewelry Workshop this is more
than just a business providing
employment and badly needed income
it also gives women the freedom to
expose their appalling treatment in a
male-dominated society
we designed this dress and this hands we
use this hands because these are the
hands of a man who touch a girl or woman
on this tree tell me how often do you
get do you feel harassed on the street
yourself it happened and everything
[Music]
and there's more to this dress than
meets the eye
what looks to me like a traditional
bridal gown is a not so thinly veiled
attack on the men who are ruining their
lives
this is one of the most amazing symbols
of their passive resistance it's a
wedding dress
to show their resistance to underage
marriage of which this scores of in this
country and the sleeve is made of the
clipped wings of birds the most
beautiful of them all peacock the the
frame of the whole wedding dress is made
out of the coloring pens of school
children
and the Train the trail is devoted to
butterflies which are start awful
vibrant and fragile and colorful and
then as they carry on being trapped in
this marriage that they don't want they
lose everything
their identity the color their voices
it's pretty powerful I think
[Music]
there is as yet no organized political
opposition to the Taliban dictatorship
of resistance from women who simply
refuse to be silenced
and that cry for recognition needs to be
heard far beyond the workshops and
classrooms hidden away in the back
streets of Kabul
it's been more than 12 months since the
Taliban sees power here
after 20 years the war is finally over
and an exhausted nation is grateful for
the end of the fighting
[Music]
but the country is now facing a serious
social and economic crisis
[Music]
Food Supplies are drying up and half the
population is suffering chronic
shortages
these women wait for hours for The
Leftovers to feed their hungry children
there are increasing signs of
desperation everywhere
for decades Afghanistan has suffered
from the scourge of heroin but the
economic collapse has seen an explosion
in the number of addicts
the results
in Afghanistan but I'm interested to
know whether it's got any worse yeah it
used to be a drug addicted to be three
million I think now the population about
five or six million now
and it's not just in the city that the
problems are multiplying
[Music]
across the come the country a series of
natural disasters is fueling and
humanitarian crisis
[Music]
this Village in Kabul province has been
destroyed by flooding
those who lost their homes were
desperate for outside support
but now that Afghanistan is a pariah
state
nobody came
how hard was it to get help
when all this happened
it was almost impossible there was flood
water everywhere and we were cut off
do you feel that the rest of the world
has forgotten Afghanistan
you've had no outside help you people
are the first foreigners we have seen
nobody came
and nobody cares about us anymore focus
on uh and we call it against your guests
the West used to spend billions on aid
for Afghanistan but that has trickled
away to a fraction
these emergency rations are distributed
to cope with the devastation of the
floods
but they will do little to alleviate the
now Perpetual shortages
can you tell me what are you eating how
are you surviving how are you getting by
day to day if we get the occasional help
then we can eat lunch but if we eat
lunch then we don't have enough for the
rest of the day there is nothing to eat
but as always now in Afghanistan
whenever women try to speak for
themselves they're told to shut up we're
being told sizey there's some tribal
Elders behind who are saying can we stop
filming the women even though they're
covered in burkas so they're they're not
even allowed a voice to to say that
they're hungry
as they won't let me speak to the women
I turn to the group of youngsters all
boys who've gathered around us I want to
find out what they make of this world
where their mothers and their sisters
are silenced
a lot of girls
what do you think about that
if they don't study their future will be
destroyed and they won't have anything
to look forward to
how old are you
12 12. and what's your name
what do you want to be when you leave
school Muhammad
and what do you think your sister will
be
they should also be a doctor because we
have few doctors who are girls
but what do you think she will be though
we hope that the opening schools very
soon
the stupidity of the taliban's refusal
to educate young women is obvious even
to a bunch of 12 year old boys in a
rural Backwater
at each stop Afghanistan's dire
situation becomes clearer
this is warduk Provincial Hospital about
three hours drive from Kabul
many of the women in this Ward are very
young
some of them are child Brides forced to
marry in their early teens
[Music]
20 years old
five children 20 years old
and she had one miscarriage
she is two years old two yes
she is seven kilogram and uh
she should be 15 kilogram so she's half
of what she should weigh
child hunger has reached a crisis point
foreign
UNICEF estimates at least one million
Afghan children will die of malnutrition
this year
[Music]
everywhere I go now I'm being told the
same thing Afghanistan needs women
doctors
[Music]
but the tragedy here is that the
simplest solution is blocked by the
Taliban
but like so many women here Dr warduk is
smart enough and brave enough to fight
back
one of the problems is not enough female
Specialists yes even nowadays we don't
have these Taliban government
[Music]
secretly we have opened it
our education is going
we will never we will never listen to
these uh
stupid talking about our life
despite the danger Dr wada wants to show
me the schools she runs in defiance of
the Taliban
like the one in Kabul it's hidden away
for fear of Retribution
the desire to learn Burns as bright as
ever but these girls are going to need
so much more
and what is your message to the outside
world
they help us we which are remaining in
this country
and also they pay attention for the
future of Afghanistan
they take part in the education of the
our next Generations we are responsible
for for them also
my message
bravery and Defiance of Dr wardack and
only other women and young girls I meet
is incontestable and inspirational
but I leave Afghanistan knowing in my
heart that if the rest of the world
continues to ignore them this is a
battle for Freedom that may well prove
impossible to win
it's been a month since we left
Afghanistan and tonight I'm attending
the opening of a special exhibition
these pictures are among the last
remaining works of art done by farida
the woman whose Gallery was raided and
destroyed by the Taliban
thank you
with farida's permission we took her
pictures and smuggled them out of
Afghanistan
to show the world that she refuses to be
silenced
it's really great seeing her work
displayed here because every single
picture is a depiction of torment and
torture and anguish and represents the
all the betrayals and everything that
the women of Afghanistan have gone
through and are going through
this feels such a world away from
everything in Afghanistan
there's a real worry that
everything they're going through is
going to be forgotten
they already are being forgotten and
that's a that's a real worry to me
[Music]
my return to Afghanistan has given me a
terrifying Glimpse not just of the
present but also of the future it's one
which is entirely male dominated a
violent and oppressive dictatorship
whose inevitable social and economic
collapse is being accelerated by its
never-ending war on women
foreign
if I have to force you to think of what
Generations unable to learn what is the
future for Afghanistan under those
circumstances
total
complete Darkness
we are going to dash all of us
we will we will disappear maybe not die
physically maybe we will not die that
way but our souls will die
and the soul of this country will die
[Music]
prophecy is correct and if we forget the
women and girls of Afghanistan and allow
that to happen
it is a neglect that will shame us not
just for now but for generations to come
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]